[Music]
royal wedding fans listen up because
palace officials just shared some big
details about Megan Marco and Prince
Harry's upcoming nuptials including when
to set your alarm the lovebirds will tie
the knot on May 19th at 12:00 p.m. UK
time
that's 7:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time 4
a.m. Pacific Standard Time the couple
will ride a horse-drawn carriage through
the streets of Windsor after exchanging
their vows at st. George's Chapel a
statement from Kensington Palace
explained that the short procession will
quote provide an opportunity for more
people to come together around Windsor
and to enjoy the atmosphere of this
special day Harry is just the latest
royal to get in on the fairytale
tradition his big brother Prince William
and his bride Kate Middleton opted for
the carriage procession on their wedding
day so did his mom and dad Prince
Charles of Wales and Princess Diana in
1981 that's Harry's grandparents queen
elizabeth ii and prince philip after
saying I do in 1947 even his uncle's
Prince Edward and Prince Andrew took
carriage rides after their respective
nuptials in 1999 and 1986
[Music]